teórico rubio comerciante informal se
muestra escéptico ante la tercera
reconversión monetaria que entra en
vigor en venezuela a partir del primero
de octubre cree que la medida no
solucionará el problema de fondo una
inflación que supera el mil 700 por
ciento y que han generado la escasez de
billetes en la última década bueno
supuestamente eso no va a solucionar
nada digamos
con la parte económica yo quiera que
suben es para movilizar y administrar
todos supuestamente lo están haciendo lo
que escuche se lo están haciendo para la
broma de contabilidad ahí les a la parte
bancaria
la parte económica de gama de negocios
que yo pueda trabajar el nuevo cono
monetario es decir el nuevo circulante
tendrá seis ceros menos y se llamará
bolívar digital los analistas sostienen
que la decisión es sólo un paño de agua
caliente entonces la reconversión si es
una no es una solución es un alivio pero
la verdadera el verdadero problema es
acabar con la inflación y volver a sacar
las monedas a adaptar los sistemas esos
son costos que se reflejan en última
instancia también en la inflación y en
la economía en general
sin embargo algunos venezolanos esperan
resultados positivos
espero que sea para bien
económico desde el té blanco del 7 de su
pueblo de mejor manera
que ayuden a poder adquisitivo
risas un señor que yo lo creo
innecesario
con el bautizado bolívar digital el
gobierno también quiere impulsar aún más
las transacciones virtuales mecanismo
que se aceleró por la falta del papel
moneda y que se ha vuelto la forma común
de pago en el país la novedad real de la
reconversión será que los venezolanos
van a tener por un tiempo dinero
efectivo en sus manos